just a heartbreaking update to a story
we first brought you a few weeks ago a
north las vegas woman loses her daughter
to covet at the same time her son was
fighting to survive on a ventilator
today the family made the decision to
let him pass
the mom sat down with victoria saha at
sunrise hospital right before she went
to say her final goodbyes to her son she
joins us live from the newsroom with
more on the story you'll only see right
here on channel 8.
this was no doubt one of jamie patrick's
hardest days of her life but even in the
midst of everything she was going
through she wanted to tell everyone how
important it is to get vaccinated so no
one has to go through the same heartache
of saying goodbye to not only one child
but two
oh god it's just terrible i mean to see
both two of my kids
within a month of each other
pass up
unimaginable grief jamie patrick never
thought she would go through just seemed
so unfair
patrick lost her 39 year old daughter
brandi takovid back in july at the same
time her 38 year old son dustin was
admitted to the hospital icu also with
covid dustin was in critical condition
when patrick first spoke to us last
month but he started to make small
improvements soon after and i went
dustin
asked him wake up and look at me this is
your mom and he actually like
fluttered his eyes open and looked right
at me but dustin's lungs collapsed
earlier this week and doctors told
patrick there was nothing left for them
to do there's nothing left of his lungs
they're just like the doctor said
they're two cement blocks
you know that's how much scar tissue is
in there
[Music]
because of the because of kovid both of
her children were not vaccinated which
is why patrick feels like their deaths
could have been prevented because it is
really important to me that people
listen
to get vaccinated because
and brandon doesn't would if they
wouldn't be in here they would be home
with me you know what i mean and
then they're not they're not able to do
that
except they didn't earn
just not the same patrick was able to
spend one last night with dustin before
he was taken off the machines i just
wanted a miracle
i didn't get a miracle dustin patrick
passed away on thursday at 11 30 a.m
the hardest part about all of this is
that she firmly believed he was making
improvements and was planning his
homecoming hoping we would be there to
capture it patrick tells me when dustin
was able to communicate he said he was
going to get vaccinated as soon as he
left the hospital reporting live from
the newsroom victoria zaha 8 news now